if your heart swelled three sizes
watching the Grinch
you'll want to make sure you caught all
the amazing hidden details yippie Kay
may be lovers it's Jan here and today
I'm going to reveal 17 cool Easter eggs
and references you might have missed an
illuminations new animated movie
keep watching to the end to find out the
Grinch's secret connection to groov from
the despicable Me movies and subscribe
and leave a comments about the film for
a chance to win some awesome Grinch
merchandise The Grinch has a ton of
fabulous gadgets and inventions he puts
to use in his mission to steal Christmas
from Whoville in one particular tribute
to the animated TV special we see the
Grinch employ some springy type of
stilts which enable him to jump with
ease from one rooftop to another as he
gathers up the whose presence the new
Grinch movie tips its hat to dr. Seuss
the author of the original book in the
scene where the Grinch starts making his
Santa Claus disguise look carefully at
the model of the sewing machine which is
Theodore a shout-out to dr. Seuss's real
name Theodore Geisel a funny little
detail you might have missed is the
title of the book that the Grinch tosses
at the alarm clock when it wakes him up
playing cheery Christmas songs the book
is called spelunking for beginners which
is very appropriate for the Grinch a
spelunking refers to the activity or
hobby of exploring caves and the Grinch
of course lives in a cave on Mount
crumpit one of the roles that Benedict
Cumberbatch who voices the Grinch is
best known for his Marvel's Doctor
Strange and there's a very cool visual
not to Cumberbatch his sorcerer supreme
in an atmospheric scene in the new
Grinch movie after the holiday hating
character comes up with his wonderful
awful idea to steal Christmas we see him
walk up the stairs of his cave home and
stand in front of a circular window it's
not exactly the same but the lines
across the round window and the circular
Center do bring to mind the window of
the worlds in dr. Strange's sanctum
sanctorum in the original book an
animated TV special as well as stealing
all the whose presence the Grinch also
takes all their food even the last can
of hoo hash and there's a little
callback to that in illuminations new
movie when the Grinch realizes he's
eaten all the groceries he bought to
last him to January even his emergency
stash of whoo hash and when he goes into
Whoville to restock he sweeps a whole
load of
you hash cans off the shelf and into his
basket when Cindy Lou first bumps into
the Grinch she's on her way to post a
letter to Santa which is a nice hat tip
to how in the live-action movie Cindy
loose father was a postmaster and she
happened to meet the Grinch for the
first time at the town's post office in
the new Grinch movie Cindy lose her
style with its two braids sticking up
with pink bows is a lovely reference to
the original book where Cindy Lou had to
worry strands of hair sticking up on her
head and it's also a cool shout-out to
the 1960s TV special where she wore two
pink bows in her hair
something that infuriates the Grinch
even more than usual is when he
discovers from his nearest neighbor mr.
prickle BAM that the mayor of who-ville
wants Christmas to be three times bigger
this year and this is a subtle little
nod to how the Grinch's heart will
eventually grow three sizes by the end
of the story when the Grinch wants to
learn all about how to become like Santa
fer his dastardly plan he starts
flipping through a book called kringles
Christmas almanaque the name Kris
Kringle when spelled with a k is an
alternate name for Santa Claus and you
may well have heard that name before if
you've ever watched the classic
Christmas movie Miracle on 34th Street
when spread the reindeer who was
originally going to pull the Grinch his
sleigh ends up leaving the Grinch
references a song Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer riffing on alive from that
famous Christmas tune the Grinch
promotes max - reindeer duty saying you
will guide my sleigh tonight
the single antler that the Grinch places
on Max's head is also a little throwback
to the same thing that happened in the
book the animated TV special and the
live-action film this time though max
his antlers been enhanced with an
extendable arm to grab the swag that the
Grinch tosses down to him during the
great Christmas heist and as the Grinch
orders max to get to work there's a
funny moment as the little dog pulls at
the enormous sleigh and instead of
moving it forward he just ends up
burrowing down into the snow before he
finally summons up enough strength to
pull himself up and set off it's an
amusing moment which echoes our similar
scene in the TV special where the Grinch
is sleigh was so laden with everything
he'd stolen from Whoville that max just
couldn't get himself up out of the snow
and stayed like that pretty much all the
way back to Mount crumpit
a little difference in the new Grinch
movie is that in this version the Grinch
steals Christmas from Cindy Liu's house
last of all where as in all the other
versions her home is the first stop on
his Yuletide raid the new Grinch movie
does however acknowledge the original
order as the meter on the Grinch of
sleigh counts down the number of houses
he's robbed on when he gets to Cindy
Liu's home the meter reads number one
the new movie also has a couple of
Easter eggs to another of dr. Seuss's
most famous books The Cat in the Hat in
the Grinch the Green Grove was a red and
white striped scarf when he goes food
shopping in Whoville and he also dons a
red and white striped tie when he visits
Cindy news house and both of these echo
the cat in the hat's iconic stripey red
and white hat as an illumination film
The Grinch also has a number of hat tips
to previous movies by the animation
studio in Despicable Me 3 we already saw
Margo wearing a Grinch on one of her
shirts and the clothing related
connections between the movies continues
in this latest film first up is the
stripey dark colored scarf that the
Grinch was during his raid on mr.
Brickell Baum's house the Grinch's
muffler looks an awful lot like grooves
signature scarf from the despicable Me
movies there's also a nod to Agnes
fluffy unicorn obsession in the Grinch
as the Hoos get their Christmas photos
taken you can see that group its family
are also fans of fluffy unicorns though
they're one has blue rather than pink
hair like Agnes's and Cindy Liu's friend
is he also has a similar to unicorn by
her bed if you were wondering who
narrated the new Grinch movie while it's
none other than singer-songwriter
Pharrell Williams he's a regular
contributor to illuminations movies and
composed numerous themes and songs
including the oscar-nominated happy for
the despicable Me movies now did you
spot any other cool Easter eggs in the
movie and who was your favorite
character let me know in the comments
below and remember to subscribe for a
chance to win one of these cool Grinch
merch packs tapleft to watch my video
with the biggest differences between all
the Grinch movies or tap right for
another video you're sure to like if you
enjoyed this I really appreciate a
thumbs up and a share thanks for
watching and see you next time you PK
movie lovers